et aux états unis la procédure est en
cours concernant la sorte d' obligation
vaccinale voulue par joe biden est un
autre dossier ce jour au tribunal entre
une association de médecins et l'a aidé
à l'agencé américaine des médicaments
l'organisation de professionnels de
santé souhaite pouvoir rendre publiques
les données de la rda concernant le
vaccin fader et s'offusque la réponse
des autorités
explications de notre correspondant aux
états unis thomas bonnin une
organisation se présentant pour la
transparence de la santé publique aux
états unis a déposé un recours pour
avoir accès aux données complète du
vaccin kaiser en faisant appel à une loi
américaine sur la liberté de
l'information
ils réclament que la f10 l agence
américaine des médicaments publie les
quelques 300 29 mille pages en sa
possession et qui ont conduit à
l'approbation complète du vaccin weiser
par cette autorité sanitaire c'était au
mois d'août dernier alors face au
silence pour le moment de la f10 est
elle cette organisation a déposé une
plainte afin de convenir d'un agenda
pour la publication de ces données ils
disent vouloir une diffusion rapide car
selon leur avocat le rythme normal dans
une procédure similaire dans le cadre de
cette loi de liberté de l'information
est un rythme de 500 pages par mois ce
qui veut dire qu'à ce rythme il faudra
55 ans pour que la f10 est publie
l'intégralité des documents
cela a pris précisément 108 jours à
lagence des médicaments et des produits
alimentaires entre le moment où fire a
commencé à produire les documents pour
l'autorisation et le moment où l'agencé
a autorisé le vaccin files heures alors
qu'elle peut conduire une analyse
intense des documents de files heures en
108 jours elle demande maintenant plus
de vingt mille jours pour rendre ces
documents accessibles au public
les plaignants disent donc ne pas
vouloir attendre
2076 pour que la f10 et publient tous
ces documents autour du vaccin à pfizer
il estime que ce sont des informations
d'importance nationale car en ce moment
vous le savez à des obligations de
vaccination sont imposés aux états unis